في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اكد رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني ان
الفساد اخطر من داعش والارهاب وقال انه
اطلق عليه صفه جائحه الفساد بصراحه لا
توجد خطوط حمراء في مجال مكافحه الفساد
ابدا وانا منذ اليوم الاول في جلسه
التكليف اطلقت مصطلح جائحه الفساد وانا
اعني هذا المصطلح لان الفساد هو التحدي
رقم واحد الان للدوله العراقيه مو داعش
الفساد
الفساد هو الذي يعطل التنميه هو الذي يؤخر
الاعمار هو الذي يساهم في هدر الاموال
التي تاتي من ايراداتنا في هذه الفتره
ايرادات النفطيه اللي يفترض ان تستغل
بالشكل الصحيح والمدروس
للفساد فقط السرقه بالمناسبه الفساد ان
تستخدم الاموال في قرارات مو صحيحه الان
عندك ايرادات
ماليه يفترض توجهها للمكان الصحيح اللي
يفعل قطاعات مهمه لتحريك الاقتصاد الوطني